John McCain and I have really met on
just one occasion and Senator McCain had
very often said you know a number of
things about me that I thought were
often insulting and I think unfair and I
and I think it's too bad because I you
know the funny thing is a lot of the
things that infuriate Republicans about
Senator McCain are things I tend to be
more agreement with them on some of the
things like immigration or the gang of
14 or judicial elections and so on but
in any case the what time I met senator
mccain i met him in a congressional
hearing and i decided he was actually
seated there waiting to speak because as
the senator he has to go in the first
panel because his time is valuable and
then this the FEC Chairman I was on the
second panel because my time is kind of
valuable and then ordinary citizens were
relegated to the third panel they had to
wade through all the hearing you know so
senator mccain was waiting to speak and
I went up and thought I'd shake his hand
and say hi and you'd see that I don't
have little horns in and you know it
would break the ice and we would be able
to talk because he refused he had been
unwilling to beat with me and so I went
up to talk to them and I said senator
and he held out his hand and and you
know kind of instinctively and I took
standard anybody looked up and he saw it
was he he yanked his hand out of mind
he's I'm not going to shake your hand
and he said you're a bully and a coward
and you have no regard for the
Constitution and kind of berated me for
several minutes and you know I this is
not a story this first time I heard told
the story on camera and I don't normally
tell it I have a great deal of respect
for Senator McCain as a bona fide
American hero as a man who's
accomplished a great deal but you know
he doesn't need to be this way toward
people who ought to be his you know sort
of political allies on a lot of things
and I really think that that he has a
certain you know anger on this issue I
think in part because he really doesn't
understand it and so he just gets very
frustrated with these people why are
they opposed to me on this it must be a
sort of a personal thing on their part
that they would do that and and I feel
bad about that but anyway that's my
relationship centre
you